[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from the rachael ray prep kitchen where
I'm joined by Rachael Ray
funny finding me here weird weird we
don't we're she's an award-winning TV
host author media mogul celebrity chef
and the only guest in hot ones history
to ever mainline Blair's Megadeath sauce
with liquid rage off of a spoon come on
I want to be a girl who could you all
number 10 but today it's me in the hot
seat Rachael's gonna put me through a
culinary crash course we're gonna be
making a very special dish that you can
make at home Rachel what are we making
today and we are making my husband's
favorite dish carbonara
carbonara is bacon and egg pasta it's
originally a Roman dish and most people
think that it's made with cream it is
not it is made with eggs and bacon in
this case pancetta or guanciale my
husband likes garlic and everything so
we're gonna put plenty of garlic in ours
but for carbonara it's really about the
technique of making it and it's a very
sexy dish it's simple but if you master
it right and you make it chances are
you're in saks a bachelor pad
classy single I am this will help you I
appreciate that
that's what I did I need all the help I
can get first of all it's a very quick
cooking dish you're going to for every
one pound of pasta you're going to bring
to a boil five to six quarts of water
whenever you cook dry pasta you have to
season the water like liberally season
the water she paper taste it with a
spoon and say oh that tastes well
seasoned you need a large skillet next
to that you're going to put over very
moderate heat put them next to each
other so you can pull the pasta from the
cooking water and drop it into the pan
all right this is pancetta very sexy
[Music]
no but the dish itself okay just eating
the pasta you know and it's silky creamy
you know there's no cream in it yeah
yeah
how much cooking do you do you know
you're somebody who's always champion
that you don't need to be a classically
trained chef in order to throw down in
the kitchen and I'm one of these guys is
so intimidated by pots and pans that I
basically seamless every meal I'm like a
latchkey kid you know so you literally
don't cook Wow all right we're gonna
have some stuff fall off a truck for you
okay cool first of all choked up on your
back
come here and then curl your fingers
around proper and then you're going to
slice down and away from your body down
and away from your body don't be afraid
of the board down in a way don't saw how
am i doing not terrible so hold this
together
always keep your fingers curled under
when you're using a knife on this hand
right like that's Paul yep all right and
you move the knife along the cutting
board and you keep moving your fingers
back okay what we're gonna do is for one
pound of pasta you need six yolks not
bad very good put it over here now you
got most of it garbage Bowl very good
cracking on the counter how's that is
that better no no we have found
something you can do Oh for good good
good five okay one more six don't ever
let them tell you you can't
all right dreams do come true
okay this is a whisk and that's all you
have to do to whisk go back and forth
very fast don't hold it like a delicate
flower hold it with your whole hand to
get the power because you want to make
whipped cream when there's there you go
look at me whisk look at you let me cook
that up
alright whipping that work nice now
you're going to add both of these
cheeses harm and pecorino that Barinas
sheep's milk cheese parmesan milk cheese
pecorino is salty and tangy harm is
buttered nutty we're gonna put in a fat
handful of each cheese ok now you're
ready to put stuff in the pan olive oil
a little olive oil coat the bottom of
the pan add all the pork and start
breaking it up a little bit so you
really do you have any equipment in your
kitchen like a year ago like the pilot
went out I my stovetop yeah and like I
just haven't even addressed it you don't
even have a stove I've like an oven but
like it yeah I don't use the stovetop
did you know that there are people like
me out there no that's scary I mean
everybody knows how to make something I
thought ok so now that your pancetta has
rendered some of its fats and it's
starting to light brown a little bit
shaking the pan good for you
you can drop your pasta in the water huh
or most of the pasta in the water get
the wine little wine need to start
drinking early today I think okay with a
little wine in the pan and now we're
gonna turn him down
and then I just let him hang out till
our pastas ready cool mixture pasta with
your tongs really like pick it off just
to get it going you need to change the
temperature of these eggs and raise it
so that they don't scramble when you put
it in the pan while you're whisking I'm
gonna pour this in there why 'allah
whisking that's important this creamy
sauce and it smells so good
chew this pan we're now going to add a
little pepper we'll salt it at the end
cuz there's salt in the cheese so taste
it and then add salt when you're cooking
dry pasta you always read the side of
the bag it'll say eight minutes or nine
minutes or ten minutes right you stop
cooking this 1 minute before that time
so if it says eight cook at seven well I
got it twice the box because it's going
to continue to cook it's called carry
over cooking it will continue to cook in
the hot pan while you're tossing it with
the sauce I feel like I'm getting my
crash course this I feel like I'm gonna
mess it up like six or seven times but
that's why you do it right that's why
you get on stage you know like no
stand-ups gonna kill it the first time
they hit an open by exactly and if you
cook once you'll cook twice if you cook
twice you'll cook three times you gotta
get your training wheels going right I'm
just gonna make the best spaghetti
carbonara you ever seen in your life
okay and I'm gonna send you a pic I have
faith I really do you do I do not a lot
but maybe a little boom now add your
sauce and now we're going to keep this
moving as it's picking up and bubbles
see already how it's thickening up and
bubbling yeah and getting silky and
gorgeous it's all working together you
know the sauce is helping to cook is
soaking up this doesn't look like that's
cream in it that's what everybody thinks
there's cream in it it's not it's just
properly made look how beautiful that is
so yours we used all of your stuff it's
generous of you to say that no we did it
Utley it's all yours
look
sexy that is in there beautiful it's so
sexy how is it I don't say this lightly
it's the best pasta I've ever made in my
entire life
tire life I think you look gorgeous
it is textbook that is exactly what
carbonara is supposed to look like and
there you have it now you know how to
make perfect creamy spaghetti carbonara
at home now I know how to make
everything you for the credit don't it's
amazing it's perfect it really is
everybody grab a fork everybody I want
for us come on get in here
[Music]